[Musique]
qui est avec nous encore une fois
Raphaël Jacob Timothée naphtali que l'on
voit pas qu'on va voir dans une mini
seconde historien merci de New York que
l'on connaît et Maître Eric Lissan merci
beaucoup d'être là parce que c'est pas
le même système de droit alors nous on
voilà on a besoin de d'un éclairage d'un
ancien procureur comme vous êtes ancien
procureur avocat merci d'être là AZ
revenons au début je vous demandais en
quelques secondes de nous rappeler
qu'est-ce qu'on reproche à Donald Trump
voilà donc il ferait face à 34 chefs
d'accusation on connaît pas encore les
détails c'est dans cette affaire de
versement d'argent à cette personne avec
qui il aurait une liaison en 2006 une
liaison qu'il a toujours liée niée dans
notre chambre en 2006 avec stomie
Daniels donc l'avocat de Donald Trump
lui aurait remis 130
000 dollars cet argent là n'a pas été
comptabilisé dans les cantes de
l'organisation de Donald Trump on a pas
nécessaire pour des frais juridiques et
c'est ce qui irait à l'encontre ce qui
violerait en fait le financement de la
loi sur le financement des campagnes
électorales donc c'est vraiment
là-dessus que le Grand Jury a tranché et
a dit qu'il y a assez de preuves pour
que l'ancien président soit mis en
accusation maître Éric lesson je vais
aller tout de suite à vous parce
qu'expliquer nous parce que nous on n'a
pas ça des jurés des citoyens qui
décident d'accuser ou non nous les jurés
décident de déclarer coupable ou non
coupable mais en amont du processus ça
n'existe pas expliquer nous comment ça
fonctionne
alors ça c'est une institution c'est
vrai que ça date de avant même
l'histoire des États-Unis c'est une
institution anglo-saxon mais ça a
vraiment repris ses couleurs nous
pouvons dit dans les dernières 100 ans
parce que c'est utilisé comme comme
une tôle une un outil
pour faire obliger les témoins de
prendre serment et elles vont les
populations de donner
leurs paroles sous serment et aussi on
peut utiliser ça pour obliger les gens à
produire des documents et c'est là que
le procureur qui a fait ça avec une
peinture
à l'état de New York dans le comté de
Manhattan de New York et
il a travers avec pendant presque 12
mois sur ces sujets là ils ont déjà
produit les situations et une conviction
contre la société familiale de
transport et aussi contre le chef de
comptabilité et de cette société a
envoyé qui est actuellement en prison
donc eux ils travaillent en secret
pourquoi cet ancré car c'est pas certain
au début de l'enquête quelle sera les
résultats en cas où il y a pas
d'occupation formelle normalement on
donne pas des publicité à un travail de
la grande durée c'est aussi en secret
pour protéger les témoins si jamais ils
s'emmène assez par quelqu'un qui est le
sujet de l'enquête mais eux ils sont eux
ils dépendants c'est eux qui votent déjà
est-ce qu'il y a la preuve là qui mérite
l'occupation c'est eux qui décident
normalement ils sont d'accord avec le
procureur mais n'est pas passe à 100
personnes et c'est justement cette
caution citoyenne
Timothée naphtali qui fait que des gens
disent mais justement ce n'est pas un
processus politique partisan puisqu'il y
a des citoyens que l'on doit convaincre
est-ce que ça l'abri de toute critique
quand même parce qu'on le voit il y a
beaucoup de républicains qui disent
c'est une
l'appareil judiciaire a été politisée
dans ce que c'est
nous sommes dans une période très
partisanale aux États-Unis alors pour
cette raison il y aura beaucoup beaucoup
de critiques et maintenant il y a des
jurys qui se siègent à New York à
Atlanta et aussi à Washington
les trois jury sont en train de décider
si Donald Trump s'il y aura une
incultation publique maintenant
le jury à New York a fait sa décision a
pris sa décision et peut-être on va voir
la même chose
et la même chose à Washington dans les
semaines qui viennent
assez discussion sont prises par des
citoyens ordinaires qui se siègent comme
le maître a été créé qui se siège a pour
décider s'il y a assez de preuves pour
que ça soit nécessaire pour une
incubation et une cette fois-ci à Niort
qu'ils ont dit ils ont décidé oui ou la
majorité de a décidé oui parce que dans
une démocratie Raphaël et Azeb est
Timothée et mettre Lisa dans une
démocratie remettre en question la
droiture du système judiciaire là c'est
c'est ça ne va pas très bien alors
Raphaël hier sur Fox News notamment
c'était très clair que le procureur
Brague là c'était le décrit comme un
clone partisan et que aucune crédibilité
est-ce que c'est pas un jeu dangereux
tout ça mais en fait ça va me permettre
de répondre à la question précédente
également à répondre à cette question si
c'est-à-dire que non Patrice le fait que
ce soit composé de simples citoyens ça
ne rend pas le système à l'abri de tout
reproche de toute critique du planctum
bien au contraire la première chose je
pense qu'on doit mentionner par rapport
à ça c'est que oui c'est vrai que ce
sont des de simples citoyens qui ont été
choisis aléatoirement à la base ce qui
est également vrai
qu'ils ont été choisis dans une
juridiction Manhattan dans le comté de
Queen qui a voté au niveau présidentiel
en 2020 à plus de 72% pour Joe Biden
donc ce qu'on dit du côté de Monsieur
Trump et c'est partisans c'est on veut
bien croire que ce sont des citoyens
mais c'est des citoyens ce sont des
citoyens qui ont été pris dans un pôle
qui est complètement
démocrate à la base donc il y a ça comme
considération deuxièmement pour ce qui
est justement de cette espèce de cri de
ralliement qu'on a eu parce que c'était
carrément ça à Fox hier heure après
heure intervenant après intervenant
écoutez on a eu l'avocat un des avocats
de notre chambre qui était allé en
nombre pour promettre qu'on allait non
seulement battre mais humilier Harding
brag devant les tribunaux et la réaction
de l'audience qui était présent c'était
pas simplement d'applaudir c'était de
rugir donc on a vraiment politiquement
je vous dirais un effet de ralliement
encore une fois qui était entièrement
prévisible qui est très semblable à
celui qu'on avait vu après après la
percussion marago et qu'on observe
présentement et qui sert tout au moins
dans le court terme au sein du parti
républicain Donald Trump je reviens à
mes deux invités américains
Timothée naphtali Eric mettre les ânes
est-ce que on peut être étonné quand on
va lire le détail mettre les âmes des 34
mise en accusation est-ce que peut avoir
des choses qui vont nous étonner
c'est possible car jusqu'à là nous
n'avons pas pu regarder ce qui est
normal le document formel nous avons
mardi
donc jusque entre ici et mardi c'est que
l'aspectation nous sommes presque
certains qui y aura plusieurs
accusations qui vise l'affaire sur méden
news et notamment l'objectif de ces
paiements de 130 millions de dollars en
total et qui était de faire en sorte
d'obstruction en ingérence vis-à-vis de
l'élection présidentielle de 2016
car il a pas voulu que le public lettera
Trump n'a pas voulu était quand le sens
de ces informations donc il y a des
règles fédérales qui visent et de l'état
aussi de New York il ne peut plus
compliqué qui vise sur cette sujet là
qui dit voilà c'est une paiement si vous
le faisez ça doit se transférant pour le
public sache ce que vous avez fait c'est
une sorte financière financièrement de
la campagne électorale mais hors de ça
il y a d'autres choses et il semble que
oui si vraiment il y a 34
c'est quand même c'est beaucoup et c'est
en augmentant le jeu à ce qui risque
d'un enfant pour le niveau de la
condamnation
de terme en prison alors qu'est-ce qui
dit il peut voir il peut avoir en plus
nous avons vu déjà dans la dans le
procès de la société familiale de
transition et dans le proche de le
processus
il y a eu de frôles fiscal de bancaire
de frôle vis-à-vis des sociétés
d'assurance et ça c'est des sujets sur
lesquels l'État de New York le bureau
d'arbres se sont mis pendant
presque des années maintenant on verra
avec eux
avec l'avocat général de l'État de New
York donc c'est ça que je crois que
nous allons voir en plus
monsieur naphtali vous êtes historien je
fais appel à l'histoire c'est la
première fois on le dit hein
j'entendais beaucoup de gens des
commentateurs américains dire quand on
s'attaque un président là le seuil même
si tous les citoyens sont égaux bien sûr
mais le seuil doit être quand même plus
élevé parce qu'on peut pas se permettre
une courbe ne peut pas se perdre de
passez-moi l'expression de manquer son
coup contre un ancien président qu'en
pensez-vous Timothée
[Musique]
pour des raisons politiques ce n'était
pas le cas jusqu'à maintenant mais
d'après nos fondateurs nos fondateurs il
fallait traiter les anciens présidents
comme les citoyens ordinaires et c'est
une faute de la tradition américaine que
l'on a dû attendre de siècles pour voir
ce qui est passé hier c'est très très
important pour la santé politique et
nationale que l'ancien président qui est
peut-être capable des violations
criminelles soit jugées
on verra parce que Monsieur Trump
puisqu'il est jugé comme un citoyen
comme un autre il y a la présomption
d'innocence alors on verra d'ici là
parce qu'il y aura on serait étonné
peut-être coupable donc il y aura un
procès d'ici là à Z est-ce que c'est
parce que Raphaël était très sûr hier il
disait ça va l'aider il va aider fédérer
tous les républicains comment vous voyez
les prochains jours dans la famille
républicaine à Z pour pour les
démocrates c'est presque un cadeau là si
c'est Trump on va parler que d'autres
chambres dans les prochains jours
peut-être qu'il va carrément ça va
s'agir de 30 ans cette campagne
électorale de 2024 donc pour le moment
ça mousse sa popularité tous les
républicains se rallient derrière lui et
cette affaire de stomie Daniel c'était
peut-être la moins convaincante entre
guillemets même des démocrates sont
contre et certains démocrates disent
carrément que c'est aussi politique donc
ils rejoignent un peu le corps
républicain par rapport à l'affaire en
Géorgie ou les dossiers classés au même
les émeutes du 6 janvier ou c'était
vraiment évident ce qui s'est passé aux
États-Unis alors que cette affaire de
somide Agnès même un procureur disait
faut vraiment que les arguments là soit
béton là pour pour que le président
l'ancien président américain soit
reconnu coupable donc on est vraiment en
terrain inconnu évidemment là les chefs
d'accusation sont sous scellés mais pour
le moment ça veut dire que dans notre
champ ben là si les républicains
derrière lui il va devenir le candidat
républicain pour les élections de 2024
pour Joe Biden il est con il sera
content certainement d'avoir de l'argent
comme opposant au lieu de rendre des
sentis là c'est plus inconnu parce qu'il
n'a pas le même passé que dans notre
chambre donc ça aurait été peut-être
plus menaçant pour Joe Biden donc c'est
un peu comme ça qu'on le voit ici c'est
intéressant Raphaël parce que dans un
premier temps ça peut l'aider pour la
pour la convention républicaine mais
dans un deuxième temps ça fait quand
même un peu désordre être candidat
présidentiel alors qu'on assiste à tout
seul je suis entièrement d'accord avec
la lecture Casa vient de donner c'est à
dire que dans le court terme c'est pour
ça que depuis hier ce sont exactement
les termes que j'utilise dans le court
terme ça l'aide dans le plus long terme
c'est un cadeau empoisonné pour lui de
façon plus fondamentale pour la partie
républicain voici où le parti est pris
parti républicain est prêt entre l'arbre
et l'écorce d'un côté on a environ 60%
des électeurs républicains qui est dans
sondage après sondage dire disent
s'opposer à ce qu'on inculpe dans notre
chambre il est encore à ce jour de loin
le candidat numéro 1 du parti encore une
fois ce qui est en train de se produire
l'aide encore plus ça s'emparer
éventuellement on verra évidemment le
développement au courant des prochains
mois d'investir du parti républicain en
même temps de l'autre côté ce qui est
également vrai c'est que lorsqu'on
raciste plus large et qu'on ne sonne pas
seulement les électeurs républicains
mais l'ensemble des électeurs américains
comme la fin université cette semaine
c'est près de 60 % qui disent que le
fait d'être inculpé devrait le
disqualifier automatiquement de la
présidence à nouveau donc le parti s'il
continue à se rallier derrière de notre
chambre ça va pas nécessairement à
l'abattoir monsieur baiden est également
vulnérable à certains égards et encore
une fois c'est c'est dans beaucoup de
temps mais reste qu'on est en train de
se rallier derrière un candidat qui est
de plus en plus problématique pour le
masque critique des lecteurs américains
je reviens je reviens avec en dernière
question avec cette division profonde
Timothée naphtali on a fait une émission
il y a deux ans là-dessus l'Amérique
divisé en deux de voir quand même dans
un réseau qui est très écouté Fox News
ork une discrédit total sur le système
de justice est-ce que ça ne va pas
laisser des traces je vous demande
d'être rapide chacune d'entre vous les
quatre mettre laissant est-ce que ça ne
va pas laisser des traces cette division
impossible vraiment de répondre mais à
mon avis personnel
même si tu en faisait des attaque il y a
une base électorale qui lui soutient
malgré tout et il s'en fout de tout ce
qui se passait si le procès se démarre
comme normalement pour toute autre
personne et on voit vraiment que les
éléments du dossier les éléments de
crime sont là je crois que finalement ça
va se résoudre proprement et ça ça va
mal finalement pour toi mais ça va ça va
prendre des mois peut-être 12 15 mois
pour terminer donc c'est un processus
longues et pendant ce moment-là je crois
que c'est vrai que tout le pays serait
dans une mesure susceptible
à toute manière des choses même des
actes de violence qui sont provoquées
ces trompes trouvent que c'est dans son
intérêt de provoquer des choses donc
voilà le risque ce matin
d'après moi Patrice lalutte et pour la
longue terme si les gens disent qu'on
peut pas faire une inculpation publique
contre dans notre chambre parce que ça
va
profondément divisé le pays américain ça
veut dire qu'on peut pas avoir une
système criminel aux États-Unis
maintenant si les jurys pensent qu'il y
a assez de preuves pour pousser à une
inculpation il faut le faire pour
protéger notre système juridique très
clair Raphaël et Azem conclusion Raphaël
entièrement en accord avec Monsieur
nathani à la fois sur le point qui vient
de faire celui qui l'a fait précédemment
sur le front c'est vrai qu'en principe
on doit dans une démocratie où tous les
citoyens sont égaux devant la loi les
traiter comme tel or voici le problème
pour ce qui est du bride confiance de
dizaines potentiellement de millions
d'électeurs de dans leur champ et
d'électeurs républicains ici on commence
à appliquer ça à Donald Trump il faut
l'appliquer sur toute la ligne et les
exemples on va pouvoir commencer on a
déjà commencé à les sortir et dans
certains cas ce sont des exemples qui
sont légitimes Bill Clinton en parlant
d'ex président il sait par juré est-ce
qu'on va lui mettre les menottes enter
Biden le fils du président actuel il a
été en possession de crack est-ce qu'on
va lui passer les menottes c'est là que
ça devient drôlement glissant d'un point
de vue de santé démocratique à cause du
brie de confiance envers les
institutions et plus fondamentalement le
système de justice c'est d'ailleurs ce
que répète les partisans du train et les
chroniqueurs en disant c'est drôle le
premier qui redevient citoyen ordinaire
c'est Monsieur Trump drôlement AZ je
pense que il y a une responsabilité
médiatique sur ce sujet là parce que
quand vous écoutez les Fox News c'est
une victime c'est que vous écoutez CNN
c'est voilà personne et au-dessus des
lois donc quand on entend majorité qui
dit que les démocrates viennent de
déclarer la guerre civile ce sont des
mots quand même très fort et dangereux
et je pense qu'il y aura une
responsabilité des grands réseaux
américains justement pour pas alimenter
la cette division qui déchire l'Amérique
depuis 2016 finalement mais qui est
tellement rentable pour eux c'est ça le
problème hier soir c'était un cirque en
tout cas merci beaucoup à vous quatre on
va en reparler c'est donc mardi que tout
ça aura lieu on verra ce qu'il y aura
des menottes enfin bref on verra tout ça
merci beaucoup à vous quatre bonne fin
de semaine merci au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI